vomi tous les matins je dors pas
beaucoup je dors mal je pense que je
suis plus à masquer nord
[Musique]
pour l'année 2011 j'ai payé pour
travailler j'ai patrice et avant six
mois
[Musique]
le procès fait à l'elysée par la table
10 900 lignes pour respecter toutes les
normes sanitaires et protection des
clients et des services
[Musique]
des gémissements la pac gagnant est
c'était juste avant la fin des vacances
scolaires donc
niveau du restaurant le stock
des pommes on avait des réservations
on a du style stocks c'est un mois j'ai
passé la nourriture mais je n'ai donné
en association matin mais si la perte
sèche les papes au changement isation
installations
[Musique]
on
chômage partiel c'est bien c'est une
aide de superbes pour les salariés ce ce
que l'on peut dire c'est que c'est nous
qui avant son argent les premiers mois
[Musique]
où
alors le fonceur il a été gelée touché
après plusieurs mois de bataille parce
qu'à chaque fois on n'entre jamais dans
les classes comme on dit dans le jargon
à tout est dans la raquette
si vous fermez votre boîte aux revenus
derrière les poteaux l'aide pour vivre
vous avez les banquiers je vous envoie
des spécialités sur votre maison pour
massacrer au vigan
il faut leur dire
tj d'argent occulte m dans deux mois
ligue 1
[Musique]
c'est très important d'avoir une épaule
à qui on peut parler et supportent
aux sautes d'humeur qui les comprend
d'avoir des enfants top
comment
[Musique]
pour les sites d'aulnay mes enfants
m'ont dit
papa tu as fais pas qu'elle est
tous nos joueurs on va les grands de
l'argent aux pauvres
[Musique]
dans mon entourage j'ai ma voisine qui
était juste en face de chez moi qui ai
un restants et puis deux générations
pam ont bien suivi le premier confinant
elle avait 36 ans ça reste en hausse
une institution dans le secteur lorsque
ils ont refermé pour le deuxième profil
mans est autorisée que certains routiers
à ouvrir lfa par la liste et le
lendemain elle s'est pendue
c'est son fils de 11 ans a décroché
je
et pour nous c'était dur
[Musique]
disons que s'il ya une chose qu'on
surnommait communication sur les
les aigles psychologique déjà ça c'est
une chose est sûre tous deux donné
une lueur d'espoir c'est d'expliquer où
les entrepreneurs vous inquiétez pas on
va vous aider et vous allez vous en
sortir
le message et il y est pas l'argent
[Musique]
et moi je suis prêt ce qu'il appelle
et lors de ces parce que souvent le
restaurateur at on trop vite
prendre des décisions importantes de
gestion qui amène à l'aigle accusations
et donc il ya des drames et donc moi
aujourd'hui je suis à deux jeunes gens
que j'ai sauvé ma boîte on va s'en
sortir et
si je peux aider mes collègues je le
ferai